[Music]
how i describe my upbringing was very
british
i'm unapologetically black
brought up by my mum and my nan and my
nan's jamaican so very heavily
influenced by that it was very
empowering and we was always taught what
it's like to be a strong black female
strong black person
generation and my mother was the first
generation so for her something i've
learned and understood
as a black woman growing up in england
for that time
must have been really hard
how that influenced me as a child was
you know at school you got different
attention obviously i was then first
generation of being mixed race you know
being mixed race what a lot of people
don't talk about you do go for a large
period of your life with a bit of
identity crisis shy
felt like not comfortable to speak it's
definitely made who i am now and i
definitely feel like i had to go for all
those traumas so i can be the voice for
those who can't speak up
black history month in this country has
been going on for 33 years and it's only
now is starting to be highlighted
our history cannot fit into a month
george floyd died so you could
understand it because you could see it
but racism here is insidious
it's done very smartly it's done in a
way that you can easily ignore
but if you are black
you feel it because that's what you've
gone through that's what you lived
but also we need to understand that
trauma
and racism comes in all shapes and sizes
racism is
not getting that job not having
black people within your businesses
if you have any friends who are black
just chat to them and say can you teach
me about your culture
black history month is also a
celebration of what
black british people have done for
the country a lot of history has been
deleted
and a lot of people know black people as
slaves who come so it's my duty to show
that we have also come from kings and
queens and we also cannot become even
more
my ultimate goal is to stay true to
myself keep learning about my own
culture and other cultures around me get
everyone else to
understand in one of my spoken word
pieces i say we're more than slaves with
unnamed graves
[Music]